- We all loved you, obviously,
when you're a part of a show like "Castle"
that lasts for eight seasons,
you tend to have a fan
base for life from that.
So I'm just curious, though,
because you now went
into executive producing
and different roles, like,
behind the scenes, too.
What do you, do you think
you learned anything?
Like, I know that you
were acting on that show
and I know that that was
kind of what you did there,
but is there something you
think you learned from there
in that eight seasons?
Were you watching everybody,
were you wanting to end up doing
what you're doing right now?
- Yeah, that's actually something
that I do talk about
with people on and off.
It's the idea of there are some actors,
there are some performers, and
I'm guessing even vocalists,
who, they're exclusively kind
of focused on that world.
And then there are some
actors who are storytellers
and who really are curious
about the wider scope
of how do we put this thing together?
And I've always fallen
under that umbrella.
So even when we were shooting "Castle",
I was always the one who was
sitting at video village,
talking with the directors,
talking with the writers,
talking with producers, asking about why--
- Curious.
- What's the difference.
Yeah, what's the difference
between having a character
focused up here or a
character focused down there.
And everybody was so open
and so willing to share
their craft with me,
from camera operators who let
me run the camera sometimes,
to our set designers, and
architects, and carpenters,
and everybody, you know, like
their doors were open to me.
And that was such a gift.
And I ended up getting so much information
just by sitting there,
just by being there.
And I didn't realize after eight years
how much now I'm almost
subconsciously unconsciously capable
of contributing to a story.
And I've reaped the rewards
of a lot of that now,
in this phase, as an
executive producer on a show.
And I'm really, I enjoy it.
I enjoy contributing to
the story on that level.
- It's just really cool.
It just shows that you're curious
and you're invested in it.
It shows that in the show that you're,
that you're that kind of
interested in the story,
and every part counts.
That's my favorite part of watching shows,
when you can tell that the
writers or the producers,
like, nobody's like a throw off character.
Everybody is, like, involved
in there and it all counts.
And I think when it all matters,
those are the best stories.
So great job, it's an awesome show.
- Thank you very much.